this is the earth at a time when the
dinosaurs roll on we'd actually like to
show you the dinosaurs rather than talk
about them but we decided to hire
Charlton Heston to do narration instead
we spared no expense for a thousand
years movie unintentionally inspires
Michael Bay's transformers it's a
Michael Bay movie so yes even the title
has to explode damn that was one hell of
a flashback we missed all of Earth's
awkward Paleogene years there was a PPO
Michael Bay saw Apollo 13 slammed his
fist on the table and said we must get
the exact same actor to play a ground
control guy in this movie hours okay
first of all terrible Popeye product
placement is terrible potpie second of
all you waited 10 fucking hours before
giving him shit about this okay so this
here's the Brooklyn Bridge and these are
the Twin Towers behind it which means
this Sun is definitely setting and not
rising even though every other shot in
this scene suggests it's early morning
it took five credited writers including
Tony Gilroy and JJ Abrams to bring a
plot for the big screen that can be
summed up in three words or less haha
remember in 1998 when people thought
Godzilla was gonna be huge competition
man was Godzilla wrong also this
represents Michael Bay's feelings about
Roland Emmerich it must be hard hating
your twin that's racist asteroids also
racist I can see why I spent so much
time destroying them on my atari 2600
movie makes you think it's killed one
black comic and quickly introduces
another one to restore the balance
unlikely what dates the movie more the
Saddam Hussein reference or casting the
star of hangin with mr. Cooper 82
percent of the asteroids targets are
iconic landmarks hungry Michael Bay
humanizes this exploding building with
this great shot of humans dying director
inserts himself into the movie like an
unwanted penis inserting itself into
your least favorite orifice
I'm rats easy Tom means we're about to
be introduced to a bunch of ragtag
individuals who are a little rough
around the edges but damn it are they
good at their jobs everyone waiting
while one guy runs and finally bursts
into the room with some kind of
information cliche guy who doesn't want
his daughter sleeping around keeps her
on a remote oil rig full of horny men we
interrupt this hilarious father/daughter
boyfriend relationship movie to bring
you Armageddon that's correct
little he wants to suggest Harry is just
in with AJ and is missing him on purpose
but how do you miss on purpose from 20
yards away with a spray from a shotgun
[Music]
movie thinks it can cast vegetable
lasagna from Seinfeld without me
noticing and you know what movie is
wrong Michael Bay watched Apollo 13
again and slammed his fist on the table
and said we need to get that same actor
to play some science guy in this movie
we got 18 days that's 431 hours 15
minutes and 18 seconds I sure I'm glad
he converted that into ours that makes
it sound like so much less time leave it
to Michael Bay to stage this
conversation on a loud oil rig so grace
has to shout these lines and make the
movie even louder and more embarrassing
to Harry
we interrupt Liv Tyler's burgeoning
adulthood to bring you Armageddon we
bring in the world's best deep core
driller because it's easier for drillers
to learn how to astronaut than it would
be for astronauts to learn how to drill
somebody could show that it's kind of
like when you blast a shotgun on an oil
rig fire guy gets fired just before an
important job where they'll need him and
he will get a second chance to win back
the trust of his boss and bang the
boss's daughter with his blessing cliche
I swear to God she never told me her
more pedophile humor from Michael Bay
the man who knows what America wants in
case she confused it for Houston Maine
now there's a Pacific Ocean impact which
we think it will be it'll create a tidal
wave three miles high
so you're saying it'll make a deep
impact basically the worst parts of the
Bible so we'd also be experiencing that
section where all those dudes began
other dudes who begat other dudes by
design
NASA was thankfully already using this
guy's design for their Mars drill you
know John's science it's an art is it a
science or an art I do this I'm going to
want to take my own men sure you just
criticize them for trying to use guys
with only eight months of drilling
experience you can get your drillers
physically ready to go into space in two
weeks drilling czar astronaut ins for
pussies they might first start with
every
don't worry he's probably in that same
bar where gambit was so easy to find an
x-men origins Wolverine I mean the guys
always in bars he doesn't have a home
address or anything so be sure to check
all of them first you were trying to
stop a motorcycle and this is the
blockade formation you decide to go with
cops pick up all the oil rig dudes
except for a J for that guy we gotta
send Harry himself out to pick him up
because it's not like time is of the
essence or anything like Mount hours lag
AJ and all the other drillers were on
the rig when the military picked up
Harry an 18-hour flight and then you
figure a few hours for NASA to explain
everything and in that amount of time AJ
has found and purchased his own oil rig
to be the president of these boys
scatter all over the country when they
get back to land from the offshore oil
rig but when the feds going round them
up they are all delivered at precisely
the exact time that's incredible never
see pulp fiction
haha Bruce Willis and Steve Buscemi were
in that movie rogue drillers all get
medical examinations in the same room at
the same time because it's easier for
them to show off in front of their
friends that way and nearly naked
Michael Clarke Duncan his comedy man why
did the psychoanalysis rooms need to be
soundproofed psychology montages montage
woman with large breasts woman with
medium breasts this guy thinks about hot
women even more than I do physically
survive the trip why are you asking the
psychologist this question why did you
even do psychological testing at all if
physical was your only parameter talk
about the wrong stuff haha reference to
a vastly superior movie that no one
watches anymore because it's 16 hours
long
what's next 71 you're the first
civilians to ever Seraph NASA just
happens to also be developing top-secret
advanced space shuttles they didn't know
they would need and there are so many
Aerosmith songs on the soundtrack I
don't think they missed a thing time to
check back in on that relationship
Michael Bay makes his movies big dumb
and loud which is fine but then he goes
and does this which blowed his movies to
70 hours apiece no joke 70 hours that's
how long these movies are now it's time
for underwater simulation underwater
simulation is announced while everyone
is still way the fuck out in the desert
screens dizziness your security risk
here that people don't know a big
asteroid is about to hit the earth but
wouldn't there be widespread panic after
man hadn't got destroyed does anyone
remember that those boys are ready to
snap they asked
they hold off the street they also had
the choice to say no to the job but yeah
let's keep pretending like they're here
against their own free will I'm not
asking you I'm telling NASA just go with
the original plan with the astronaut
drillers if they got too nervous about
Harry's crew Harry doesn't hold all the
cards does he this fucking song putting
cheese on something is sort of the
defining characteristic what makes a
cracker cracker also easily accessible
racism is a defining characteristic of a
cracker do you think it's possible than
anyone else in the world doing this very
same thing at this very same room what
the romantic getaway or the animal
cracker bull this is like being
serenaded by your father while having
sex movie decides to show us what
happened to April O'Neil and Casey Jones
after the end of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles dirty dirty pg-13 strip clubs
this place is nothing but filth to my
x-rated mind The Hobbit all the action
both angry strip club patrons show up to
fight the heroes because it's not what
the movie deserves but it's what the
movie needs right now we randomly
inserts another asteroid into the
picture when there's a lull in the
action the death of 50,000 people in
Shanghai yesterday has rattled movie has
completely glossed over the destruction
of Manhattan earlier or have they
completely gotten over getting destroyed
by the meteor shower we could go nasa's
an emergency launch preparation in
cooperation with russia and japanese
Billy Bob Thornton's Mission Control
boss character also acting as NASA's
media spokesperson I shouldn't drag you
around all those that's correct
promise me that unprofitable promises
PACS also more fucking relationship
statuses movie inadvertently inspires
the entire visual aesthetic for Man of
Steel the Bible calls this day
Armageddon that is a hell of a lead-in
for telling all the world for the first
time about the impending crisis I mean
you just started talking
remember how no one knows anything about
the asteroid and all they know is
there's a secret shuttle mission taking
off maybe ease into that shit dog
Armageddon roll credits he is French
people doing classic French things
gathering around and listened with the
radio at their favorite cafe even Gaston
the motorcycle guy showed up
Ireland Asia this place salesman daddy
oh sure when he's a loser April O'Neill
hates him but now that he's a loser in a
spacesuit she loves him again I gotta
get me a spacesuit freedom crew
independence proved neither the freedom
crew nor the independence crew can go
wherever they want okay so good so I
guess the one day vacation they took
solved all the issues concerning the
mission they just went into the
simulators and bang that got no problem
after a day of romantic getaway is
visiting divorced wives strippers in
jail you know we're sitting on four
million pounds of fuel one nuclear
weapon expose me
thank God the weather was really good
really if you think about how often real
NASA launches get scrubbed for even a
hint of foul weather and the fact that
these assholes only have a window of
days or hours or else they're dead
mother nature really did the masala
movie tries to trick you into thinking
you're watching Fargo with its casting
choices mission deems it necessary for
AJ to do this important job he's never
done before so that chaos can happen
also for what reason all love does is
come up here and press a button that
anyone could have pressed in between the
launch in the finale we need some
boosted up tensions so naturally there's
a convenient leak on the space station
that nearly kills everyone cool long
sustained shot shows a Michael Bay we
wish we could see more of but never will
two shuttles survive this proximity to
the explosion with superficial enough
damage to just carry on and do the
mission because space we're now in the
mission the destruction of Mir makes no
news broadcast on start praying about
right now what an asshole Liv Tyler is
born asteroid debris is a dangerous or a
threat to the shuttles it's only here to
make cool moon impact noises engaging
oh so now the debris is a concern coffee
cup shattering on the floor in slow
motion to signify a character's despair
cliche movie will now seamlessly cut
back and forth between the freedom and
independent shuttles with shaky camera
movement and zero context so you'll have
no idea what the hell is going on
Captain America here blew the landing by
26 miles was he seriously expecting the
captain to land this plane perfectly
after all that stuff they went through
the most realistic part of the movie is
that one of these shuttles crashed
trying to land on an asteroid but then
it's nearly destroyed by the fact that
AJ and the others survived this remember
back when you were stripping down the
armadillos for only necessary how did
the machine guns make the cut was doing
this trickier part of some NASA
contingency plan also this is the same
shuttle that withstood the launch
Earth's atmosphere 22 G travel around
the moon tons of asteroid debris impacts
and crash-landed onset asteroid right no
comment position you have to pan over
the tag heuer logo for every fucking
clock shot did they kidnap your children
the lunar gravity's put her in a spin
this wasn't expected this was unexpected
but the need for machine guns on the
armadillo we totally called that let's
see they need to restore radio
communications someone wants to fire a
nuke right now a more level-headed
person does not want to fire the nuke
right now there's launch codes on this
red paper this just turned into Crimson
Tide I wouldn't NASA be the primary
scientific advisors to the president in
a situation like this how does he
possibly have anyone on his end telling
him Manasa is wrong how did that advisor
get their job is it Pauly Shore I
realize you need a villain of sorts and
explosion happy politicians are always
an easy target but this is beyond stupid
what do you do with a gun in space duh
he's obviously gonna blast open a door
on the side of the shuttle to drive an
armadillo out of right
come on come on stop that bomb right now
treason colonel Willie sharp would be
dead in real life are you sure you don't
have any brain injuries red and blue
with Jesus really they did all the other
necessary steps to disarm the bomb up
until this point and now they both
forget which wire to cut red the blue
clock constantly adds time when it ticks
down and do I cut the red wire or blue
wire and bomb detonation cliche now
here's a reference that you probably
won't know it just sounded like Harry
tried to pick up the platinum bar in the
loud room want an explanation
google it not here to hold your hand
through these things the Grand Canyon
they have stuck the nuke in this thing
they had detailed maps about what the
asteroid was made of and divided it into
sections so how do they miss this did
they even need to drill this armadillo
is about to make a successful flight
across a canyon running into many huge
rocks have problems with the thrusters
and no one is gonna die and I'm okay
with that and I am NOT okay with that
it's not the water king must be a
dramatic moment in the script then this
NASA either works or completely fails
depending on the needs of the story
rockhound is about to demonstrate why
you don't put these things on space
vehicles space dimension also I don't
blame the movie for constantly putting
obstacles in the way of our heroes but
space dementia come on don't you mean
asteroid quick smaller asteroids
continue to target major cities because
we wouldn't care if the asteroid they
detected was headed for the Mojave
Desert or Bowling Green Kentucky and
this is why NASA wouldn't let someone's
daughter just hang out in the main
control room Affleck ex machina either
those are straws which is ridiculous or
were there wires which means he found
enough unnecessary on this space shuttle
he could dismantle and strip to come up
with six different colors of wires which
is also ridiculous isn't time a concern
when did he find time to forage and
create these straws slide 10 the hero
sacrifices himself to save the world
cliche but there won't be anything to be
scared of soon because all the evil of
the world will be gone when I blow up
this asteroid
just like a 1976 Buick in a horror movie
this space vehicle won't start work
movie turns into Pink Floyd the wall for
a few seconds
and I would remove 50 sins if she'd had
just made out with Billy Bob Thornton
right here people about to go kill
Frankenstein are excited about asteroids
demise all the people celebrating the
defeat of the asteroid are from the
1950s death of my father so over it this
is touching and all but it's absolute
bullshit some random lady just showed up
at NASA and said gee yeah I'm one of
those driller astronauts she got up
there yeah he means several years ago
this little boy is his son can we come
in and get straight onto the runway when
they land oh look they let rock out
stripper girlfriend on the compound to
this pink song again fire hazard wedding
asteroid movie ends with the worst
wedding video ever also who's shooting a
wedding video with 8 millimeter film mr.
boogie Thanks that's all yes I scarce
environment imaginable
[Music]
space the final frontier the worst parts
of the Bible what he means this Old
Testament Pierre Mayer real wrath of God
type stuff fire and brimstone human
sacrifice dogs and cats living together
mass hysteria Jesus may be the fastest
sprinters but gazelles are better at
dodging and drinking
[Music]
max would like you to bring back 8-track
tapes the brass ring
bigger
[Music]
well I went in there and house gonna hit
Jesse Dixon upside to hit with it
knocked him off my mother
I reckon that didn't quite satisfy me so
I hit him again with it in the neck with
sharp aged just plumb dear could easy at
all
in the fifth your ass goes down sit in
the fifth my ass goes down damn we got
debris
[Music]
listen to em start I get a bad feeling
up here I want you to do something for
me I want you to find my wife don't ask
me how by the end you'll know how I want
you to tell her something I want you to
tell her that
[Music]
I told her it took me a while to figure
out what a jerk I been